The new stars at the Berlin zoo are relaxing
and settling into their home.
Newcomers Jiao Qing and Meng Meng have made
it past the strains of their journey over
from China.
The arrival of the two panda bears at Berlin's
airport was highly anticipated.
Especially by the director of the Berlin Zoo.
"This is because of the rarity of the animals.
They are a highly endangered species, that
has a hard time getting by in nature."
Fewer than 2000 of them live in the wild.
And they can only be found in China.
Female pandas are able to conceive for just
a couple of days a year, meaning reproduction
is rare.
Conservation workers have instituted breeding
programs to encourage more births.
Panda bears spend most of their time eating.
The pair in Berlin is given 80 kilograms of
bamboo per day.
But that's far from their most remarkable
quality, says China's ambassador to Germany.
"Panda bears are holy in China.
Panda bears are also the ambassadors of friendship
and loyalty."
Beijing is fully aware of the effect these
cute animals have, and so have been sending
their panda bears on tour around the world
for decades.
One example was in the 70s when U.S. President
Nixon visited arch enemy China.
A short time later the Washington zoo received
the gift of their first panda bears - as a
thank you and gesture of reconciliation.
The People's Republic continued to use the
system of cuddly diplomacy to reward governments
for economic or political cooperation.
Or to solidify ties of friendship between
China and other countries.
In 1999, two years after Hong Kong had been
returned to China, Chinese former vice-premier
Wu Yi gave Hong Kong's government head Tung
Chee Hwa the giant pandas An An and Jia Jia.
Two years ago, China promised to give the
Berlin Zoo the pandas while Chancellor Angela
Merkel was visiting.
She had been accompanied by investors.
Panda bears Meng meng and Jiao Qing are set
to stay in the Berlin Zoo for 15 years.
But with a caveat: China has the right to
take the bears back home anytime, if the Beijing
government sees reason to do so.